bootleg here podcast got my guy Fred
money in the building yes sir go follow
him at Fred money everywhere yes sir uh
new music on the way definitely you
gotta album out right now you got a new
album on the way with uh Jr yeah new
money out right now new money too on the
way in May and uh family ties with Jay
on dropping soon the writer of writers
yes sir let's go let's get right to it
man
[Music]
set this thing off right yes sir Kev
what up
new money too dropping soon
that new money out right now
[Music]
what up cash
hey Zeus what up stacks
let's go
look marshmallow the Buddha getting
brain from a dang can't tell if she
tutor Lane for the fame I could tell you
Maneuvers on them Instagram Stones
Marcelo Your Jeweler I'm the [__] ain't
the smell of manure got em pissed Rock
the yellowish Mueller can't you tell her
this newer blew a bag I hit Frankie all
this cash they should thank me y'all
Ball cat like the tags on the Yankee
shots made his leg do a dance now he's
stinky up there [__] where they gon rank
me Venture match the Van Cleef Betty Van
Nish knowing Fred shoot like van Fleet
grab him and it's over now I'm Zangief
wonder why I'm constantly writing and
fighting all fury like I'm Tommy and
Tyson ain't no money in your pocket but
it's probably your license gas card is
some limp you a fraud let it sink once I
look into your eyes then you lost you
can blink snatch off your disguise once
my dog get the wink would I drive a boss
in the Brinks that means it's gonna
cause just the link I mean what you
think new money in stores flying in the
b in size honey Galore looking at me
what you see onions are all got a dog
time to run it up more cause it's coming
on tour in my zone getting loaded with
the fam I ain't rapping off my phone I'm
scrolling through the gram matching
colored stones look like Frozen little
zans leave me alone can't you notice who
I am it's money hey I'm knowing you
should play around talking all that yay
once you go up you get taken down
trapping every day ain't no breaks when
we be breaking down come see where I
stay just don't stay around [__] you
see how my muscle Flex quick by the way
I hustle call me Russell Westbrook
stepping on this snake I can't end up in
no death grip punches causing trouble
like a tussle you get that quick getting
to the checks while I'm checking off my
checklist still ain't get no rest cause
I'm Restless rapping with the vets in
the cipher you decipher who the best is
crashing out our wrecks they just
Reckless Family First getting bread or
you bum scream rocking all this rice
stuffing white in the one pan not nice
[__] with Fred you a dumb man if I
ain't nice and cab ain't a Suns fan but
believe it or not you know how I rock B
and B blowing up this spot but I'm not
no TNT represent the Block it's a lot
they're seeing me trying to register
yeah next stop DMV [__]
all right sir all right
all right Fred money hey I know you just
watched the new freestyle guess what
we're dropping them every week sometimes
more than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week